et chanter les faits john parisella la
signification de cette victoire est la
surprise quoique cela fait aussi
d'entendre c'est peut-être que monsieur
dont il ne conservera pas nécessairement
mais il n'y a pas de coeur des grands
gagnants ce soir ses preuves dans les
sondages parce que les sondages ont
quasiment détermine essentiellement
qu'est-ce qui était de résultats et ce
soir me parle de pas concédé mais si la
maja commence à dépasser de 2 500 les
histoires sont importants donc faudrait
qu'ils contestent ou demander des
recomptages dans plusieurs états et je
pense que ça va peut-être pas le fait
mal paraître comme un mauvais perdant
alors pour vous c'est quand même indique
thouars série à l'arraché même s'il sait
que tel que prévu ou au baba gagnait le
collège électoral mais romeny elle est
peut-être l'emporter dans le vote
populaire ou en tout cas être vraiment
très très très proche de barack obama
et ça se joue en fait dans les
projections confessionnel du de la
victoire d'obama dans trois états
surtout celui de l'ohio mais aussi sur
virginie effleuré or dans ces trois
états la un pour cent ou moins de votes
qui sait pas qui de bois qui sépare les
deux candidats alors est ce qu'il y aura
dans les chais les conseillers donné
pour amener une volonté de contester
peut-être ça ça reste à voir
je pense qu on ne le saura pas tant que
le mécanisme va pas se présenter aux
produits médias je concède la victoire
alors qu'est ce qui a été déterminant
c'est le discours d'obama de proposer
aux américains de ce fait nous confiant
je veux terminer le travail que j'avais
commencé ou à ramener qu'ils
n'approchent inspirer confiance parce
que c'est ça oui c'est ça fait bizarre
de campagne au tac à obama nous a
inspiré ce coup ici nous a pas vraiment
perret dans cette campagne déjà démontré
qu'ils étaient qui est un homme sérieux
qui avait fait des bonnes choses mais
que cet apport tu te fais au niveau des
attentes de l'ensemble des américains
mais il a démontré quand même que sur
l'économie je pense et jean reconnu que
vraiment ils étaient quelque chose de
très mauvais il se sort si d'une guerre
il subitement d'un il a sauvé les dix
lits ville de ton mobile
il y a amené obamacare qui était qui
était finalement alex fils dans un sens
ou du moins dans un jugement sadig haïti
sont attentionnés réforme des rebelles
il faut la poursuivre effectivement il
passe à l'histoire aujourd'hui barack
obama pour nous lie définitivement ah
oui c'est un deuxième mandat c'est pas
rien un président qui réussissait un
président qui se demandent plus cinq
femmes en général on tu vois c'était pas
cet enfant donc il va faire de vente
offre probablement je pense que barack
obama a gagné parce que pour lui un
adversaire très regrettable d'un on ne
serait pas ici ce soit entre 1 10 et une
élection serrée
si ce n'avait été d'un seul des barbares
un seul débat le premier débat où barack
obama n'était pas là et ont ramené avait
failli perdre la donne sans piloter a
failli perdre à paris six pieds ressaisi
après et la soirée américains se sont
remis à repenser peut-être leur choix ce
qu'ils avaient dit que ramener étape est
une alternative au choix il reste à
peine un brin dider sait comment il
réagit à l'adversité et je pense que
dans son haras obama et le sheed accord
avec charles
bien décrit fait mauvais débat ici le
prix une l'occasion notamment la crise
de leurs gants samedi à démontrer nos
leaders retrouve laisser partir sans fil
sans parler du commandant en chef
puisque rapidement qu'est ce que ça peut
changer pour les l'iran la syrie tout
c'est très rassurant pour nous les
canadiens notamment parce que là on a
quelqu'un on à la stabilité à la maison
blanche donc ça veut dire de temps sur
le plan économique sur le plan de la
politique étrangère vous allez avoir un
bien meilleur président dans les deux
prochaines années que le président obama
durant les deux premières organiques
l'ancien président geri il sait comment
ça fonctionne là devant le congrès je
pense j'espère il va être beaucoup plus
tough beaucoup plus dure beaucoup plus
engagé mais sur la politique étrangère
connaissons c'est aussi maintenant il
n'y a pas de problème donc équivoque par
la population ce soit dans des deux
premières années qui est petit plus
grande les femmes il les a pas vendu à
la population alors alors écoutez je
vous remercie
le mot de la fin peut-être vous chantiez
de quoi qu'est ce qu'on doit attendre
alors ben je pense était une élection
vraiment excitant qui aurait parié il ya
un mois que face à me promener barack
obama finirait comme ça à l'arraché ce
soir là avec trois états qui sont
contestés peut-être contestée par un
seul pourcentage de voix c'est une
vraiment une soirée tout une course
normale mais il a gagné et je pense que
eelv a pris va passer maintenant
l'histoire c'est grâce à garde les
femmes c'est le obamacare et les amener
plus loin parce qu'ils étaient tellement
de comprendre moi je pense que non
je pense que la venue plus loin il faut
qu'ils l'appliquent parce qu'une partie
est parti car on va te piquer en 2014 et
le gros défi c'est réduire le déficit et
hier je pensais bien que ce soit barack
obama que ce soit aux commandes
parce que là il connaît le dossier et
pour l'économie américaine sont censés
mieux aussi que ce soit pareil geste et
ça sert également
exactement et je pense qu'il y aura une
vision un peu plus équilibré entre le
port et dure trop les impôts et surtout
réduire les dépenses est arrivé à régler
cette histoire de paul maury aux 4,4 à
nice des trente années de wii fit un
plaisir d'être avec vous et merci à vous
sur le terrain d'abord accueilli chez
vous c'est pour vous rencontrer pour
vous